yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights
visit expressvpn.com yang
do we really want our nation represented
by the sort of person who likes sucking
up to rich people from money because
every normal person would hate this what
kind of person
likes this the most depressing story i
heard
a member of congress told me he said you
know one of the things about congress is
it's
totally broken institution nothing
happens and it turns out
fundraising is the one thing where you
feel like you've accomplished something
so
it's like doing push-ups so he says like
i can go down for an hour
and i can have my target and i can meet
my target i can feel like
holy [ __ ] i did something i accomplished
something today and you're like oh my
god this system is now
built so that the only thing you feel
proud of is your ability to raise money
because you can't do anything else you
can't legislate you can't work with
anybody you can't bring about
government services anybody's respectful
of it's just fundraising that is the
measure of success
uh there was a person running for
president hopefully he doesn't mind that
i say this
uh but senator michael bennett and one
of my colleagues
guys was with him on the plane and was
like hey so
uh what's motivating the run and he said
honestly it's so i can try and get
something done because i'm not getting
[ __ ] done in the
senate because we don't pass anything
yeah
[Music]
thrilled to have with me on yang speaks
former presidential candidate so we can
bond
over that democracy reformer
legal scholar prolific author general
powerhouse and force for intellectual
progress and reclaiming our democracy in
the united states of america
lawrence lessig lawrence thank you for
being here
thanks for having me andrew you are such
a deep thinker
on so many issues that i now believe are
core to our survival
you know and i don't want to be
hyperbolic but at this point it
literally is survival of our democracy
survival of hundreds of thousands of
americans
and you were ahead of the curve i'm
going to tell a story i don't know if
you know
um but when you ran for president in
2016
um you started like the pack to end all
packs
um and i donated i was like wow a great
idea
like this guy is onto something um
so would love and i'm sure you've
regaled people in other contexts with
your tale from the 2016 campaign trail
but would love for you to share it here
so we can perhaps
edify some folks who who don't remember
your run
as well and then we can compare some
notes
[Laughter]
well i'm i'm happy to and i'm i'm first
of all extremely honored to be
on this podcast with you uh you know as
many people know i admire so much what
you did
and we started together on that campaign
in
april of 2019
when you came to new hampshire and we
did a town hall
and i was trying to convince you the
issue you needed to think about first
was democracy reform
um and you were all game to talk about
that
uh but you know the reality is that
you've actually convinced me that the
ubi
is the number one issue we need to think
about after
democracy reform and unfortunately it's
taken a pandemic to convince
most of the world that that's true but i
think it's an extremely important lesson
you've taught
um you know now the story my story
i actually think of as a story of
optimism because you know in 2016
it was my view it's actually 2015 when
we started this
it was my view that unless we got
the nation to focus on the fundamental
problem of the corruption of this
democracy
nothing else was possible i mean you
know you got these candidates like
bernie and hillary up on stage talking
about all the amazing things they're
going to do you should have been on
stage too man
we were talking about that what was that
yeah they changed the rules on you right
yeah so so i wanted to get them to focus
on these fundamental issues and i said
like
i will run for president if i can raise
a million dollars in 30 days
and um and the way i'd run for president
is by making this issue the number one
issue the issue i talked about before
anything else like we have to commit to
fixing democracy first
and so we raised the money in less than
30 days and uh
and that's how you're like oh my gosh
now i have to do it right right
but the pollsters that we you know we
had said look
um based on what we we know you're gonna
qualify for the debates
the first challenge was that the
democratic party had a rule that said
that
you had to be uh uh you had to be listed
on a certain list of polls
and those polling companies were not
including my name
um so there's this i just want to stop
you there lawrence that was actually
really tricky for us too
yeah in 2018 they they had a bunch of
polls
and my name was not on them and then
you're like well if i'm not on the poll
then it's gonna be very hard to qualify
yes so leading up to the first debate uh
bloomberg uh
wrote up the bloomberg press wrote a big
editorial about how ridiculous this was
because you could tell
from other polling that i would have
qualified but i wasn't on the approved
list
my view at that point was okay the rule
was here's the approved list you got to
be on that list
fine the next time around we'll make it
a week before
uh at the end of october um uh my
campaign manager called me and he said
you know
we're gonna qualify you're gonna be in
the next debate um
and i said oh you know he said you gotta
get to work and preparing so i
drilled down to begin to prepare and
then at the end of the week he called me
back and he said
the democratic party has just changed
the rules for the debate you're not
going to qualify
and they had they had recrafted the rule
to like draw the boundary precisely
so that i would not qualify according to
their new specified rules
um and uh and so you know when it was
clear they were gonna
change what was the new boundary what
was the old boundary what was it well so
the rules they had originally announced
which they eventually agreed this were
there were the rules was that you had to
be at one percent
in three polls within six weeks of the
debate very reasonable
and then they uh changed the rules to
say you had to be greater than one
percent
in three polls and then they gave a
period
carving out the time before the debate
and that period was carved to
lop off polls that had qualified me
and we knew what other polls were going
to be announced and there weren't going
to be enough polls that were announced
to
qualify come on point that that was a
coincidence
they they consulted the stars
and yes oh that there was something off
that conformed
to somebody wrote me and said
pulse of the nation right somebody wrote
me and said that's with larry mandering
born
because you got very commander that's
right
but anyway i mean you know the point was
it was clear
they didn't want somebody up on stage
causing trouble around this issue and
you know
they saw what donald trump was doing on
the on the republican stage i don't
blame them in some sense but
they didn't want this issue to be
central when i tried to talk about this
issue as being central people are like
you know no i don't know people care
about health care they care about
they care about climate change they care
about student debt well that was like
the danger larry is that um it
it seems no offense to you but you seem
like a very smart guy
and so so like that the danger when you
talk about
the and you should know that um i i came
away also convinced
by our event together where i was like
he's right uh democracy reform
needs to be front and center because
we'll never actually change anything
meaningful without it
um but the the the hazard i think that
people have when you talk about it
is they think in terms of process that's
what i meant by the smart guy it's like
a smart guy you have some fixes
to the process uh and the the danger is
that people will just be like oh
you know like that this stuff is going
to be wonky and
um uninteresting but it seems like
you've had a different experience when
you talk about this because
americans realize that we right now are
not functioning
in uh democracy that's living up to the
name
yeah and this is what's so hopeful i
think you know in 2016 i couldn't get
them to talk about this you in 2020
you know our group and represent us and
n citizens united succeeded in getting
every major democratic candidate you
were one of the first
to commit to fundamental democratic
reform in the first hundred days of
their administration
including finally uh um joe biden
but i thought most dramatically was
bernie sanders who finally came around
to embracing vouchers which you had
embraced back in
april of 2019 and he had an incredibly
powerful
story about why vouchers were so
fundamental shifting power to ordinary
voters
so that they are the one driving
fundraising and the intention of
candidates
um and so you know my view is we've come
a long way in five years
we came from the issue not even you
recognize this no
no no it's not just me not at all i mean
there are a lot of people that helped
you there's a lot of people right when
we think about this issue though
uh you are the first name that comes to
mind right so so i think we're at this
moment where you know the house of
representatives passed hr one in 2019
the most important reform
legislation passed by the house since
the voting rights act of 1965.
if we get the senate if we send the dark
lord mitch mcconnell back to kentucky
and we get the presidency there is a
chance that a year from now
we will look at uh what happened and say
holy [ __ ] we have
passed fundamental reform including
public funding of congressional
campaigns and i hope um including
something more like what you were
talking about vouchers to help drive
that funding
democracy dollars yeah yeah which is
which you were very clear right up front
and then
it was so funny kirsten gillibrand's
campaign i was talking to and they're
like andrew yang says a hundred dollars
hell we're gonna say six hundred dollars
six hundred dollars per voter if
if you have three la three campaigns of
president senate and house in in one
cycle
so you sparked yes that's right
so i i think we have a real shot if we
can just get beyond the disaster
that is uh looming in november of 2020.
this is very optimistic and hr one has
many tremendous reforms in it
um what are like the top reforms that
you're excited about and to the extent
hr one's missing anything is it missing
something
yeah the most important thing in hr one
is public funding
it's missing a more robust
voucher component because the kind of
public funding it's framed around is
matching funds which is what new york
city does
and matching funds are great very
helpful but the point is you're still
appealing to a relatively small
right i mean you know most most rich
people don't realize that the average
american
can't just write a check for a hundred
dollars to a politician that's just not
within their
capacity but if they had a hundred
dollar democracy dollar the way you were
talking about it
of course what else they going to do
with it they're going to give it to
politicians so the point is
that's a more fundamental reform we've
got to build in and i know the sponsors
of hr1 are eager to think about how to
expand it so
hr1 that's the most important thing that
gerrymandering reform is incredibly
important the restoration of the voting
rights act
is astonishing that we're still fighting
about this issue but
yes that's incredibly important what
it's missing
is is much stronger support for ranked
choice voting
yeah that would have been exploding
would have been extremely important in
this democratic primary
um uh um you know as well as having an
iowa
caucus that actually worked that would
have been helpful too but
um you know i think that that's
something a lot of people are talking
about now we could we could begin to get
towards
um but i think those are the central
most important things that that
bill carried well it would be a great
leap forward to have
um matching funds for these
congressional campaigns because when
some of the candidates were seeing are
generating popular enthusiasm and that
if you got a bunch of small dollar
donors
it could add up quickly but i agree with
you people don't realize what a big deal
it is for someone to donate
10 20 50 bucks to a political campaign
one people don't have any disposable
income lying around in that way like if
you think 50 100
to them that's like a really big deal
but the second thing is people are so
burnt by politics that it it takes like
a really big
connection or attachment to motivate
someone to donate to a candidate it's
one reason why i'm so appreciative of
the
yang gang rallying behind my campaign
because i was really bad at dialing for
dollars larry i was terrible at it so i
was like oh man i hope some
everyday america is the worst
you know when i was doing it and i did
it very little when we came to
you know close to getting to the million
dollars my campaign manager sat me down
and said you've got to call these people
and make sure it happens okay so i did
it
but the thing i was thinking as i was
doing it is okay i hate this
every normal person would hate this what
kind of person
likes this because you know that's the
kind of person
we're attracting to run for congress and
you're like do we really want
our nation represented by the sort of
person who likes sucking up to rich
people from money because
that's not how you build leadership in a
nation i
joke about it all the time that you'd
have to be out of your mind
to go to a cubicle farm and dial for
dollars and think that was the way it
ought to be
uh the problem is that as soon as you're
in that cubicle farm then you're like
well i had to
swim through [ __ ] to get here yeah and
so now this system's going to protect me
because i'm an incumbent i start out
with let's say a million dollar
advantage over
uh tom dicker sally or whoever's gonna
run against me
uh so here it is like this moat
now benefits me so i guess i will suck
it up
and take advantage of the fact that i
can do a soul-crushing activity better
than the next person
the most depressing story i heard a
member of congress told me he said you
know
one of the things about congress is it's
totally broken institution nothing
happens
and it turns out fundraising is the one
thing where you feel like you've
accomplished something so it's like
doing push-ups so he says like
i can go down for an hour and i can have
my target
and i can meet my target i can feel like
holy [ __ ] i did something i accomplished
something today
and you're like oh my god this system is
now built so that the only thing you
feel proud of
is your ability to raise money because
you can't do anything else you can't
legislate you can't work with anybody
you can't bring about
government services anybody's respectful
of it's just fundraising that is the
measure of success
that is very dark and very human and so
important uh there was a person running
for president
hopefully he doesn't mind that i say
this but senator michael bennett
and one of my colleagues was with him
on the plane and was like okay so uh
what's motivating the run and he said
honestly it's so i can try and get
something done because i'm not getting
[ __ ] done
in the senate because we don't pass
anything
yeah and so it speaks to the same thing
where if you have a good person who
wants to accomplish something
unfortunately dialing for dollars at
least gives them that momentary
reinforcement
that they they got something good done
or good i mean you know
they succeeded yeah yeah that's like
such a microcosm of something i i think
so he
one of the things i said on the trail
was that in american life today if you
have money on one side and people on the
other
the money's going to win like who's
going to win and people all like
uniformly in my events they were like
yeah the money's going to win and so
this is the case i made for a democracy
dollar i said we have to unify the
people on the money and then you have a
chance
then the legislators started responding
to you again
[Music]
here at yangspeaks we are all about
doing things better and products of the
future and what's the mattress of the
future
it's helix sleep oh my gosh this thing
is custom designed for you you go to the
helix quiz
and then you talk about how firm you
want the mattress
whether you sleep on your side back or
stomach i'll leave it to you to guess
how
andrew bank sleeps but after you take
the quiz you order the mattress it gets
sent to you
you can add sheets or pillows or
whatever you need and
then it arrives it's the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2019
and 2020 by gq and wired magazine
so if you're looking for a mattress and
you like to sleep
who does not like to sleep at this point
sleeping
is a must for us all
go to helixsleep.com take their
two-minute sleep quiz they'll match you
with a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
and they have a 10-year warranty you get
to try it out for 100
nights risk free that's right you can
get a new awesome mattress and sleep on
it for 99 days risk-free
and ship that thing back they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but they know you're gonna keep it
because you'll never have slept better
andrew you have answered this question
do you think you can sleep anywhere i
feel like i've seen you sleep in very
uncomfortable positions
on the iowa bus or in your subaru or in
various campaign vehicles yeah i can
sleep anywhere
that's true yeah um but i still like a
good mattress
you know i mean oh yeah i don't wake up
with a crick in the neck so helix is
important i just got mine
it's super comfortable it's nice they
also ship it right to your door it's in
this
relatively heavy but compact package so
it's the size of a thimble it's like a
freaking cartoon no i'm kidding
but they're offering two hundred dollars
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
yang that's h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
yang for up to 200 off and some free
[Applause]
pillows
so to me there's this whole chain
of problems that we're trying to resolve
and hr one goes part of the way
around getting money to different types
of candidates gerrymandering
voter access and negating voter
suppression
uh is another and then you climb up the
chained congress and then you have
all the corporate interests that are in
their ear all of the time
the fact that they can't get anything
done and then you have
depending upon how you look at it either
above or below that you have the media
organizations
uh that are driven by dollars of their
own in the form of advertising
revenue and so if you are a
website or news channel you figured out
that if you gin up sentiments
around a particular set of ideas and a
particular audience then you're going to
stimulate more engagement get more money
and so it starts skewing your editorial
incentives in various ways
so that you present news that excites
or angers your your audience yeah the
politics of hate
is the business model of cable
television it's the business model of
digital platforms and
it's incredibly profitable it just
happens to be
incredibly destructive for the capacity
of a democracy to do anything
um and yet that is a reality that we see
in the way media operates it's the
reality around fundraising i mean the
fact is if you've got to raise money the
old-fashioned way
the most reliable technique you've got
is the politics of hate to sort of gin
up hatred to the other side
make it seem like they're the devil if
they have any power at all it'll be the
end of the republic
and that drives the passion to get money
into your side and if we don't
find a way to build democracy on top of
a platform that doesn't depend on making
us stupid
and hate each other we're not going to
build a democracy and
and and i agree it's really important to
recognize it's not just campaign finance
reform
a finance i mean that's a symptom of a
deeper problem
but the cable and the digital problem is
really profound and
given the first amendment there's
relatively little the government can do
about it but we need to think creatively
about
how we're going to address that problem
too i have
an idea that i'm trying to develop
around it because it to me so you have
and so
let's put uh let's put people here
and then media corporate interests sort
of as a layer between
um people and legislators and we'll put
legislators on top and then legislators
have their own
messed up incentives so to me the media
lair is vital
because right now we're turning on each
other we're more polarized than ever a
lot of people
are losing faith that we can get
anything done together
uh which is being borne out by the facts
you have congress walking away from
a recovery act uh even though it's
obvious to all of us that
we need to extend benefits and uh you
know so the polarization is going to
destroy us
and the media unfortunately benefits
from that polarization so what do you do
so here's my suggestion you're right
that uh we have first amendment
protections and no one necessarily wants
uh folks to to be uh governing
what can and can't be said in various
news outlets um
on the other side you have over a
thousand local newspapers that have gone
out of
business because they can't survive uh
you know craigslist and internet ads
have
disrupted their their advertising models
and so
to me if you want a functioning
democracy you need to have local papers
and there have been studies that showed
that if you don't have
any local news source in your town then
you just vote
on very polarized lines and nothing ever
gets done is bad for democracy and when
i was going around the country in iowa
new hampshire and ohio and everywhere
else
they were very passionate about this
because they they lost their paper and
you kind of lose your identity if you
don't have a local paper
so step one is to say look local
journalism or journalism generally
is a public good in a functioning
democracy and we need a way to
to pay for it that is not advertising or
subscription yes
and so why don't you take an andrew yang
like idea um
you know you could imagine giving people
uh
uh journalism dollars that they could
use to fund their local
local papers um i i completely agree
with you and you know one thing we
forget
is that at the birth of this nation the
biggest
expenditures the government made were
expenditures designed to knit together
an
infrastructure of information the post
office was the forefront of that i mean
now
we're trying to starve the post office
to defeat uh the election but
at that time the post office was the
biggest employer and
and the biggest debate was whether they
should make newspapers free
to distribute or charge them a tiny
little amount
to filter out you know just junk but
their commitment to subsidize the
production of news and information and
the spread of information was absolute
and they realized you couldn't have a
nation if you didn't have an
infrastructure of informed citizens i
mean jefferson's idea here is really
powerful and supportive
and what we've done is we've evolved
into a nation where
you know we've handed over the
production of information
to these platforms whose incentives
have nothing to do with informing us in
a balanced and meaningful way their
incentives are to sell ads the opposite
unfortunately yeah
yeah and until we change those
incentives until that business model has
changed
um i don't know what we do now there are
alternatives i mean this
this right here like a a podcast podcast
you know
i like to think about the um you know do
you know the slow food movement
uh which basically says like if you just
cook your food there's like this little
media movement
yeah it's the slow democracy movement
slow democracy movement like if we do
democracy
in certain places we can do it well and
if we do it in other places we do it
poorly so if you do democracy on twitter
or facebook it's no good because you're
reacting to the kind of politics of hate
and you're being driven by ad
incentives and all of that is bad but if
you do politics
in like podcasts or long form narrative
or town hall environments then that's
more fixed to us as humans like we have
a chance to reflect and to think and to
hear both sides and to get deep on an
issue
and so the question isn't so much
whether we blow up twitter or facebook
the question is how can we channel
more of our political attention into
places where the attention span is
greater than five seconds i mean you
must have hit this all the time
you know ubi is an obvious point
once you understand it but to understand
it it takes five minutes at least
or maybe 10 minutes an hour to explain
it
and how many you know i mean you know
i'm a professor so i i
i have the opportunity to force people
to listen to me the lecture for an hour
but if you're out there on the campaign
trail and you've got like 30 seconds to
make your pitch
how are you gonna explain an idea like
ubi to in a way that people can
understand but
if you could bring them into a place
like this a podcast where they listen
for an hour to a conversation
then p ordinary people anybody can come
around to understanding it so the point
is not that you need smart people
you need smart environments it's not
that you need like
phds running government you just need
people placed in a context where they
have an opportunity
to actually understand before you ask
them what they want to do
and we could build that environment we
just have no incentive to build it right
now
i'm a big believer in common sense and
the judgment
of ordinary americans you go to them and
you say hey
if you had a choice between bailing out
wall street or homeowners what should
you choose
you know like virtually every normal
person would have been like
let's keep people in their homes and uh
you know i think that's a superior
judgment than the one we actually
uh adopted in oh wait no not again and
again and again yeah
so i agree with you that you don't need
degrees or irradiation necessarily you
just need good information
and an environment that's actually
rewarded for providing you
information in a way or judgment or
discussion
or argument like in a way that's uh
balanced and reasonable
and meant to provide you the tools to
participate
in in your own democracy so
here's the opportunity maybe here's what
i figured out
and this is the big plan i'm going to
try and propose uh is that
so all these local papers have gone out
of existence we believe
that we need to bring them back i
believe or support the ones that are
hanging on and so what you said about
journalism dollars is right
is where i'm going um but the way that
we consume information now
is so uh varied that my thought would be
that it would essentially be a
micropayment model tied to our attention
so
let's imagine that every u.s citizen had
uh 50 a month that goes to the stuff
that they
pay attention to and so then there's and
you know you can't make it complicated
for people so it's essentially just tied
to whatever
uh article i look at or if if i
subscribe to something you know i can
use some of it on that
and then we could end up creating like a
positive set of supports for some of the
journalism that we want
without having to go down this road of
like you can't say this you can't say
that in other words you reward the
positive
uh without trying to circumscribe
uh communications in other sectors and
you make it so that like
the the unreasonable media
is more clearly such
as i always say like if you've got like
the carnival barker
on the side uh you know yelling about
things then you can be like look
you can yell like you know it's your
right it's just you're not going to
participate
in this uh in this journalism dollars
set of uh incentives and rewards
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what we need more than ever
right now freaking mail
you know so many people are at home
just living remotely working remotely
and you need to send stuff you need to
receive stuff
the post office is a vital public good
and people who think that it needs to
necessarily make money
uh are off base and how the heck do you
mail stuff and avoid a trip to the post
office
stamps.com is what we used on the
campaign trail and it's tremendous you
get
like a digital post office on your
computer the comfort of your own home or
office
you can print postage you can make it
happen
straight from the computer you save time
and money
and right now listeners get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment this is
not a scale that you can jump on
yourself but it will weigh
just about anything you're gonna mail
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in yang that's stamps.com
and then enter yang
[Applause]
[Music]
well so is journalism dollars directed
to just the bottom line or is it
directed to certain kind of activities
that we know we can't do anymore i mean
like the most important activity
journalism used to do
was investigative journalism i mean the
only way to keep local governments
honest
was for a reporter to show up at city
hall meetings um
or to you know go to city hall and talk
to people and now there are no reporters
anymore so the corruption at the local
level is exploding
um so is journalism dollars driven
towards
uh like supporting particular kinds of
journalism or it's just
we're going to give you money based on
the number of eyeballs that you happen
to attract
so the initial thought and part of the
reason why i liked
the um i like being
paid based on your attention is i'm also
concerned that we have a creative
atmosphere that is
increasingly impossible for musicians
artists
of all kinds as well as journalists but
i agree with you that there's some
fundamental
public purpose to journalism one of the
things i suggested on the campaign trail
was
that we publicly fund a number of
investigative journalists per
congressional district with the thinking
being
like you know what if you you have a
congressional district i'm sure there's
important stuff going on there
and so you have these journalism fellows
that uh you have a great idea
and and we had it it's like the same
number as like congressman you get
it's federally funded they're there like
you would probably knight someone from
within the community it'd be
this big honor we essentially have to
make journalism this
uh publicly valued profession and i got
into this giant
not not giant it was like a minor
twitter spat
of this issue where i was like look uh
journalism's dying and we need a new
model to fix it and then some
journalists uh took issue with me and
said you know journalism's adapting and
we're kept tearing us a new thing and
then i just went on this
mini diatribe i was like look 1000 plus
local paper is out of existence i've
been to those towns people
are are devastated by their loss
every journalism every journalist knows
hundreds or thousands of colleagues
who've lost their jobs
over this last period of time if a young
person comes to you and asks
about going into the field you try and
scare them off
you're like this is not the field you
want you wanna
to go into you have major media outlets
like time magazine
um or not time yeah time
uh being bought by media moguls oh no
sorry tech moguls as like a trophy
property
you know washington post uh you know
like bought by bezos
uh and so we we have this market
distortion of journalism
that is going to make in my opinion a
functional democracy impossible to
resuscitate or rejuvenate well i i think
it's a really important
idea for creativity in general this my i
don't know if you know
my colleague terry fisher who wrote this
really wonderful book called promises to
keep about copyright
and his idea for copyright was you know
copyright used to be obsessed with
controlling copies
in the digital age that makes no sense
instead what we ought to do is just make
it
totally trivially easy for people to
copy things all over the place
but then artists get paid based on the
frequency with which their content gets
consumed
so you know if you happen to be an
incredibly popular artist like we're
tracking who's consuming what and you
get paid based on the fact that
people want to listen to you 10 times
more than i'll love it i never
understand that but that just seems to
be the reality of music so
so that's a way of like encouraging
people to create and encouraging the
sharing of creativity
but also guaranteeing that artists get
paid and i think that would work for a
good chunk of the journalism part but i
do think that
the other idea you were talking about is
really critical you need journalists
who in some sense are not thinking about
the bottom line yeah
the great thing the new york times can
do is they can say to a investigative
journalist like take a year
just think about this for a year and at
the end of it if we've got something we
got something if we don't we don't but
i'm not gonna your job is not gonna hang
on whether you get a pulitzer prize
winning uh article at the end
and so i think these fellowships is a
really great idea like pro publica
supports the idea of basically creating
effectively fellowships in journalism
we could multiply that i love the
congressional district because you want
to really drive it into the local
jurisdictions and say like there are 10
journalist fellow you know
propublica fellows in every district um
and then let these people you know be
judged locally about whether they're
doing good work but at least you would
begin to drive attention to an area
which right now
there's no return for like why would you
ever talk about it
yeah so there are so many things we we
need to do in media
sector in particular it's funny and you
you were ahead of me on this as well
uh you know your last book talked about
a lot of these issues i kind of lived it
i lived my version
of it yeah but i'm convinced
uh changing the incentives for media has
to be part of the
the puzzle or part of the process
because at this point people are getting
their information
in very limited ways and when you talk
about podcasts too this is
like a thing that i'm very sensitive to
it's like podcasts work for folks like
you and i that have a following
um but it's it's not like a real
replacement
like do i love podcasts yes i do uh you
know obviously
[Laughter]
yeah we're on it um and that was one of
the things that some folks in the media
came back to me about uh where they said
like look like we have these podcasts uh
and i said well you have that podcast
because you're a big deal journalist and
you actually can get audience but it's
not like the
the format does not replace
other forms of journalism it certainly
doesn't replace the investigative
journalism you're talking
about yeah i i don't think it replaces
it all i'm trying to think about is
like how do we get people yeah how do we
get people into the right context
for the kind of question we want them to
think about i mean this is
i think what's interesting here is i
just think this is the sort of problem
we never had to worry about before like
serious problems were in context where
you had serious attention to think about
it you had time to think about it
and now we got to make sure that's
possible instead of like imagining
people are going to make a judgment
about who the democratic nominee is
going to be
uh based on their twitter feed or their
facebook news feed
um like how do we get them into a place
where they have a better opportunity
to think about the range of people so
you know you experience new hampshire
an extraordinary context where people
meet people face to face over the course
of two years by the end of that two-year
period everybody knew who andrew yang
was everybody
knew your character they didn't know you
threw your ads on i don't know if you
had television ads but they didn't know
you through
ads yeah we spent approximately
i think it was something like uh four or
five million on uh
in new hampshire alone that's great but
that's not how they do new hampshire
but not just because of that the point
is they could see you face to face and
know your character i mean i remember
that town hall
where uh you know you appeal to our
children and like what are we leaving
our children and you
your eyes welled up and i looked out in
the audience and people were weeping
that was that was because new hampshire
puts
politics at a personal retail level
and so people have a deep understanding
of the character because of the place
that they begin to meet them and we got
to think that way about these problems
generally like
you know it's okay to think about what
brand of toothpaste you need to be
consuming at the kind of twitter level
attention span like you don't need to
worry about that so much but who the
next president should be
or like whether ubi should be at the
center of any economic plan
that takes real thought not not smart
thought it just takes as you were saying
common sense thought
but common sense driven by people who
have an opportunity to understand both
sides
and to reflect on it in a way that gives
them confidence
[Music]
at yang speaks we think that our data
should be ours and the fact is right now
your
internet service provider knows and
tracks every single website
you visit what's worse is they can sell
that information
to tech giants and data brokers who then
use that data
to target ads at you expressvpn is one
way to put a stop to this it creates
a secure tunnel between you and the
internet so that your
activity can't be seen by anyone it's
like you magically remote in
on a computer that's located someplace
far far away totally anonymous
expressvpn is used by high-end companies
all the time it's the world's number one
rated
virtual private network by cnet wired
the verge and countless others
so if you're like me and believe that
your online activity
is yours and yours alone secure yourself
by visiting expressvpn dot com slash
yang today
and use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang and you can get an extra three
months for free
that's expressvpn.com
okay so at this point we've uh enacted
some level of
uh democracy reform among people in
financing elections we've somehow fixed
the media
and then now we're at the top of the
chain and you have these legislators who
are there
and they're getting nothing done they're
dialing for dollars just to feel good
about themselves
uh people are in despair over what the
heck we can do
to change the culture in washington
so one of the things i came out for was
term limits
in part because i think that government
service ought to be
a term of service and not a
multi-decade-long career
and i think your institutional
institutionalization
goes up over time and dc
i don't know how much time you spend in
dc but dc is such an institutional town
like you get there and you can almost
feel like
that these like uh scales forming
like around like yourself where you just
become more
um uh like part of the
environment um so what
can be done at that top level to help
improve legislator incentives
well i i like the idea of term limits
but only if it's tied to changing the
way we fund campaigns i think it does no
good at all
if we continue to fund campaigns in the
same way because you know whether you're
a fifth term or a tenth term person if
you're still getting money from the same
people you're still responding to the
same incentives
but what i think what's striking
especially in our party
is how hard it is to make this argument
at a really
practical personal level so you know in
my state
um this there's a democratic primary
being fought right now between joe
kennedy
and uh marky who's like you know a
really
is a really great senator who's been in
washington for
40 years now ed markey
ed markey's votes except for his vote on
iraq and his unwillingness to discipline
president obama and his more hawkish
moments i think
practically every one of ed markey's
votes i love
but the point is there's something weird
about the democratic party that it
allows itself to be filled with these
people who think that they should go to
washington and just stay
i mean the average age of the democratic
leadership is 72
the average age of the republican
leadership is 58.
so there's this huge difference between
the parties and we we need a way to
articulate the idea
do your term of services you put it i
think nicely and then go home
not because you failed or not because we
don't like you or not because
in some sense this is a punishment
but because we need a party that
encourages new people to come in
and to feel like there's a place for
them to come in and for something for
something for them to do especially the
democrats because as you know
the most important demographic are
people under the age of 30.
if we can't get those people to turn out
and vote at the same percentage that
people over the age of 65 vote we never
win
and yet the only seems to be the way to
do that is begin to bring generations in
who are
you know at least aware or closer to
this generation um
and one way to do that is to whether
it's formal term limits or just a kind
of norm
you've been there long enough you know
all praise to you for your service
but it's time to move on well i'm open
to things other than term limits
um you know there was an onion headline
that i found hysterical but also
it made me think it was the american
people
hire their own lobbyist to go to capitol
hill and then
there's a person being like i represent
the very good people the
members of congress uh so so so term
limits i know is a relatively dramatic
uh measure which i am for um for a
number of reasons i agree with you that
you couldn't do it independent of
democracy reform in the ideal world in
my mind you have
democracy dollars wherever it's a
hundred dollars so you have very much
candidates uh funded by the people and
then you had terms of service where
people
came and went and so you could speed up
a lot of what's happening in dc in my
opinion
the best congressman i i spoke to i've
spoken to a lot of them but he said
i'm just trying to get something done so
i can go home you know like that that's
actually the best attitude you can have
yeah and and he was true to his word he
did go home
[Laughter]
so and he didn't get anything done um so
he
he did half of what he set out to um
so i'm for these things but i recognize
that
uh they're relatively dramatic um and
i'm open to things that could move the
needle
in dc uh that are
things that you know people could adopt
sooner
rather than doing something as
dramatic as having term limits for
members of congress
yeah and i i think it's it's norms that
are so important i mean you know
i think we're seeing this on the dark
side of washington right now that um
you know one of the most dramatically
destructive
uh dynamics with the trump
administration
is their destruction or failure to
recognize basic norms of governance like
the appropriate way to respond to
congress the appropriate
way to tell the truth um and you know
and i think norms are a really important
regulator here and i think that the
democratic party just began articulating
a norm
you know we're going to give you a a
really important party
after you've served for 20 years in
congress and we're going to say
you've been an amazing public servant
and we're going to build up
to have a statue like the take a hint
retirement party yes
there's like the new like
congratulations
you did it that's right
any constitutional amendment for do that
we could do that tomorrow um yeah maybe
we should
it sounds like the kind of things like
various strange social clubs do
um so so that there was
um uh so that there was um
a suggestion in in this direction
um of restoring ear marks
uh and which i am for as well because i
i looked up and said okay remember that
i can't get anything done
and uh at this point i am more rewarded
by seeming like a strident warrior to my
people regardless of whether or not
anything gets done
and it drives everyone to despair and so
in an era of ear marks
you could say look i got you this uh
pork museum i got a museum for pork
like i sort of combined two ideas there
um but i i
like uh you know i funded um
like school improvements i we we funded
this
bridge restoration we actually needed uh
and so there's this feeling like that
members of congress are trying to bring
home the bacon
for their districts and then that got
attacked as a source of corruption
and wasteful spending and the rest of it
yeah well again
it depends on how you're funding
campaigns so
if you fund campaigns in the way you're
talking about funding campaigns i don't
think there's any problem with your
marks why not
um i mean there's a question of how
efficiently government resources get
allocated
because it's a hard question my
congresswoman jackie speer when i lived
in california
created his citizens commission to make
recommendations to her about earmarks
and so we held hearings
and we had people come in and present
all their ideas and you know some were
ideas like
we need this park
reconfigured other ideas like we have a
brand new way to
to deal with uh antibiotics to make it
so that they're
they're no longer um drug resistant you
know and it's a kind of
question which nobody on the panel had
any qualification to make a judgment of
but you know this guy needed fifty
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars to get this idea
going so i i have some skepticism about
the process
but if there were no fear about
corruption
because you weren't funding campaigns
through indirectly through earmarks
they're fine
the problem with earmarks in the old
system was that you would find
people basically doing an indirect quid
pro quo
so the earmark would go to a foundation
in the district
and the members of the board for that
foundations in the district would
contribute large amounts of money
to the congress person yeah to your
campaign yeah so
you got to make sure that there's no
chance for that and if you just have
public funding
of congressional campaigns there's no
chance for that so fine fix that problem
then you can have earmarks just like fix
fix that problem then you can have term
limits
the the earmarks the citizen commission
seems like genius to me
because if you can imagine a member of
congress being like hey
i'm going to bring home this money what
should we do with it and then
coming and being like we should do this
for this park we should do this for
um it was really inspirational or or
whatnot
i would love it you can even imagine
that becoming really fun and engaging
because now with technology you can say
like hey
i'm congressperson x like what do you
think we should fund in
our district these are non-hacking
results but i'm just interested in what
you all think
and then like people would be like huh
like what do i like
yeah no again institutional design is
really important so i love the idea this
is the commission
but make sure they're randomly populated
because if you have a regular citizen
commission
then again you have the incentive for
corruption so if i'm on the citizens
commission
and you know that you've got to please
me then uh in order to get the
the earmark then you'll find other ways
of pleasing me to make sure that i want
to help you get that earmark
but if we could use you know there's a
big experiment going on around the world
right now of these randomly selected
panels or sortition methods for making
citizen decisions like belgium
has created almost parallel parliament
that is just randomly selected citizens
making recommendations
and some with some force france is
experimenting with the same idea ireland
did it
iceland did it for drafting a
constitution
i think we should be doing this much
more
not so much to make decisions but at
least to make recommendations
because if you have a well represented
you know sample so randomly selected
representative of the public
relatively large uh with a chance to
deliberating being given information
i would bet 99 of the time that judgment
will be infinitely better than what
politicians would make or anybody else
i tweeted in the height of my
frustration over what's going on in
congress i said there are times when i
think that
we could pick citizens at random and
make them our leaders and wind up with a
superior result than what we are getting
uh and it got something like 100 000
likes because everyone wow yeah
everyone's feeling the same thing and a
lot of people suggested sortition they
said like
you know why don't why are we just
selecting folks i agree with you having
them as recommenders
uh would be awesome because you'd end up
with like a
perspective and voice that you wouldn't
have otherwise you probably do want to
have some kind of
check or or authority one of the reasons
why
i am so for earmarks is just i have a
sense of how you try and get
decisions through large bodies of people
and if i was a legislator
and like i go against you uh
like you know or i'm for you then it's
like well what happens like what what do
i get
or not get you know and like it and and
if you have incentives particularly who
have gerrymandered districts so you have
incentives it's like you know
it's better for me to take this extreme
position and uh and then i'll be
rewarded for it because i won't be
primaried
rather than have to stretch and say okay
what could i get on board with
uh and then if they if the leadership
comes to you and says look you get on
board with this and i will offer you
this for your district uh i do not think
that's bad
personally i feel like that's like a
necessary
uh element of having a functional
legislature
it's such an important point such an
important point because we have this
conception of congress where everybody
is supposed to be an ideologue
and everybody's supposed to remain
uncompromised in their position
so that like if you ever vote in a way
that doesn't reflect perfectly your
extreme right wing or extreme left-wing
position
you in some sense are a sinner that's
not how deliberative bodies work
the whole idea of a congress you know
let me say that i'm a left-winger and
i'm going to congress and i will try to
represent my left-wing views but
i got to work with people who are not
left-wingers they're right-wingers
and we got to make a decision for the
nation as a whole and we got to have a
mechanism
for allowing us to come to an agreement
a compromise like i'll give you this you
give me that
and so i agree with you you could
imagine earmarks being another
tool to facilitate this compromise and
that's how they were used
so long as they're not also tools for
corruption and again the simplest way to
do that is just fix campaign finance
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yangspeaks we are big believers
in taking care of ourselves
and also taking care of your mental
health now sometimes taking care of your
mental health is not possible in the
sense that you can't just
figure it out for yourself without some
help
and if you want some help there's help
available at better help which is a
digital
counseling service it's like 21st
century therapy
you connect from the comfort of your own
home can start communicating in under 24
hours and you get professional
counseling at your fingertips
totally confidential you can unload and
unlock some of the things that are
weighing you down the fact is right now
we're all struggling this is a mental
health crisis and catastrophe
but one way you can make it through is
to actually get help
and the way to get better help is just
to go to betterhelp.com
yang you'll get 10 off your first month
over 1 million people have already
started taking charge of their mental
health with better help
again that's betterhelphelp.com
yang and i will say that help can be a
variety of things so that's depression
or stress anxiety but also relationships
sleeping trauma you're just angry i'm
angry all the time
in quarantine family conflicts grief
self-esteem literally
there's the whole it runs the gamut here
at betterhelp so it's betterhelp.com
that's helpbetterhelp.com
[Applause]
when i was running for president my
great fear was that
you'd get to washington and not be able
to get anything done so i was looking
for structural changes you could make
that would actually enable you to get
something done
because the dark thing is that the folks
in washington in my mind are not really
getting rewarded for getting things done
anymore
uh they're getting rewarded for accruing
resources making the moat nice and deep
and wide so no one can challenge them
and avoiding any headline making scandal
like that those seem to be like the main
incentives and if you do those things
then
you'll be fine you'll get to stay in dc
and what happens to
the people is not actually tied to your
feet
so i was looking for ways that we could
change that up
uh one thing i'm passionate about which
i'd imagine it's a little further afield
but it goes back to the media element is
that i was
staggered by the lack of measurement
and discipline around the conversation
we're having about various things where
you say
hey is this working is this good is this
not good and then it's literally just an
argument
it's like like this was great no it's
terrible and you're like okay like what
happened there
you know it's like that you you just
look around and be and be like well is
it working
you know like to me some of the things
that
got me to run were the fact that like
we're spending twice as much as on our
health care the worst results in other
countries well that doesn't seem to be
like very uh effective uh or our life
expectancy is declining or drug
overdoses have surged to record levels
or
you know like things that objectively
you look at and say well these are not
signs of a healthy society
they're all of these things around
democracy reform too my great fear
uh lawrence is that the parties and this
is a guy
an author named philip howard said this
is that the parties will just play you
lose i lose you lose i lose over and
over again
while like our towns sink into the
ground
like the feedback mechanism between our
lives
and our leaders the fortunes
like that the link has been severed and
so now it doesn't matter
uh and then more and more people as
their lives disintegrate will then
give up hope not vote not participate
not donate twenty dollars because they
just don't believe that the system's
uh systems designed to care about them
and they're right i mean you know there
are there is an important
powerful group in america who benefit if
the government does nothing
and they want the government to do
nothing and the easiest thing to get in
washington
is to stop the government from doing
something so
doing nothing is extraordinarily
profitable to a huge class
of lobbyists and people in the private
sector
and they win because we've built you
know already we inherited
a constitutional design with checks and
balances that made it extremely hard to
get anything done
um uh francis fukuyama's work about the
um vitocracy which is what we've got
right now where
so simple to veto any substantive change
means that we basically are you know
stalemated we can't do anything and so
for stalemated
there's no climate change legislation
the um healthcare industry can continue
to charge whatever it wants for whatever
it serves pharmaceuticals get to do
whatever they want there's no
all of these public goods that we need
some way to address we can't address
can you anything yeah um and all of that
is not accidental it's because we've
they've allowed the system we've allowed
the system
to become one where if you're powerful
you can always block something
um and so what we need is a system where
that's no longer true
and one way to make that happen is to
cut this
cut the incentive connection by making
it so
congressmen are not worried about what
you know the jeff bezos equivalents or
want they're worried about what their
ordinary citizens want so if they go
home
and their citizens say you know where is
the healthcare that's affordable
and they know that that's what matters
to them raising money and getting
elected then they'll be responsive to it
it's not it's not rocket science it's
about getting the right incentives into
the system
everyone has negative power you're right
lawrence like that
and and our system is designed for
inertia uh congressman came to me
uh or i came to him and he said to me
when he arrived in dc he said
it's like the marble columns are there
to remind you that nothing will change
[Laughter]
um so we we have this uh unfortunate
kind of mini drama of like rising and
falling while nothing fundamental
gets fixed and nothing fundamental
changes and there are extraordinarily
wealthy and powerful corporations that
just benefit from nothing
big changing yeah um yeah
and and yet we find a way to get
ourselves worked up and angry about
every kind of issue without focusing on
the fact that
there's no capacity to basically steer
you know the ship so you know we're
arguing on the deck about like you know
what we're eating for dinner
without thinking about the fact that
still we can't steer the ship and the
ship is eventually
you know going to run aground and you
know this year
2020 has been as close to running in the
ground as i could have imagined
um you know uh and you know i just read
an article about
europeans looking at the united states
and saying you know as we imagine
300 000 americans dying from this
uh pandemic uh the huge proportion of
which caused by our own governmental
ineptitude um and this article was about
europeans looking at us saying
we just can't believe it like like isn't
is there no recognition
of the cost in humanity like humanity
forward for god's sake right
um you know the uh the the absolute
human costs that have been
uh suffered because of this in
ineptitude and
and a willingness to do something about
it yet here we are
still wondering whether this man will be
re-elected or whether
you know uh you know the election will
be so marred with
um corruption and ineptitude that um he
has a capacity to stay in power even
though
i can't believe the majority of
americans would want this man to be
their president
it's a heartbreaking devastating time
i'm sure people around the world are
looking
at america in disbelief and for me i
have family members who left this
country to go
to other places that had managed kovid
better where they can
live normal lives and their you know
friends who are in other
countries who aren't coming back one i
think is they might not be allowed to
come back but two they're like hey my
kids can walk around outside here in a
way that
you know like or we can go to
restaurants more appropriately because
we can go outside yeah
um it's it's a tragic
terrible time and when you talk about no
one's steering a ship
run aground i mean this is it you know
like we we have we have taken the ship
and
crashed into shore and hundreds of
thousands are dying
millions tens of millions will be out of
work we can't agree on cash relief
uh the the only hope i have is that the
pendulum will swing
dramatically uh when we're in position
to try and rebuild the country
certainly your ideas are so core and key
you definitely
moved democracy reform um up
for me from wherever it was to something
like
uh 1a or 2 or after universe basic
income because obviously i'm like this
guy you and i can alternate but the the
thing that i love
is that you ran on your heart and your
values
in 2015 2016 and then if
everything goes well like you may get a
lot of your
vision accomplished uh five years later
you know if hr one passes
and i ran on universal basic income and
hopefully it will not take five years
for us to pass out because i don't think
we have five years
i might have thought we had five years
uh a number of months ago but now
we don't have five weeks i mean you know
we need to to make big moves
well i think we should recognize our
party is going to be tested
you know i think there's a really good
chance that we
take control of congress and the
presidency and then we'll see
who our party really is because one part
of the party the part that i want to
believe in
is the reformer part the part that says
ideas like ubi
ideas like fundamental democracy reform
is what the party stands for let's do it
let's just make it happen
and they say it will happen but there's
another part of the party
that i think is still stuck in the old
ways and they say well
public funding for campaigns you know
who knows whether that will really work
let's just you know have more
transparency or like tiny little
tittles on the corners of nothing um and
i
really fear that uh if we take over and
the democrats don't go through
with these fundamental reforms then we
really
will be in a catastrophe so it's bad
enough right now given the disaster for
the president and the control of the
senate that we don't have these changes
but if we actually gain control of
congress and they don't deliver then
then i think it's time to talk about the
next stage and this
revolution because um obviously the
ordinary democratic process has not
worked
i agree there is a need and a challenge
for the democratic party to go big and
solve
some of these meaningful structural
problems so that americans can see
uh that they're not just crouching there
and uh
making some window dressing marginal
actions
and they they don't recognize it i i
fear because
some of them have been there for a long
time and their lives are very very
disconnected uh from the lives of most
everyday
americans at this point but that they
need to rise to the challenge in a very
very big way
we need to if you include the the two of
us like
we're the reform element uh
the democratic party hopefully is the
vessel for that reform
but if it is not oh my gosh will there
end up being
like a whole massive
uh collision uh
it's it's it hopefully that need
is clear to them yeah
because if if they don't deliver i mean
then we're gonna have to have another
podcast and talk about what the next
structure is
because it's not gonna be this party i
agree with you lawrence let's put a pin
in that
we'll check back in a little while and
see whether
hr one's passed whether uh the party's
rising the challenge
um but this conversation has been
awesome and edifying i learned so much
from you
and your ideas are vital to the future
of our country we need to
make them a reality as soon as possible
and i
appreciate your patriotism and service
by
stepping up five years ago and helping
show me and many others the light
seriously like i donated i was like this
guy's
uh a genius and correct and he's
highlighting something that most of us
are not thinking enough about
i appreciate it andrew and thank you so
much for running you were such an
inspiration to so many great people
and you brought them back you brought
them into politics and that was the most
important contribution you could make
oh thank you it means so much to me were
your kids yangyang was that
yeah yeah yeah
that's all i wanted my my oldest was a
little surprised that i knew andrew yang
i told him and he said no
come on you don't know andrew yeah he
said yeah
i feel grateful to know you and i'll
continue to
uh pick your brain and learn from you
every step of the way great me too
great to talk to you andrew you too be
well lawrence all the best of the family
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you